Everyone, uh, welcome to another episode
of AI that works. We are back and I
think today one of the key things that
I'm really, really excited to talk about
is a concept that has come up a few
times in our past streams, but it's
really about how to build working AI
pipelines.
Um, so for everyone that hasn't attended
before, this is a show called AI that
works. Every week we run a live
conversation where our goal is to talk
about how to build a pipeline that
actually can make real productive
examples. If you find this sort of stuff
interesting, check out our link and
we'll usually post new events there. And
we run this every single Tuesday at 10
a.m. uh for about an hour and the goal
is to get to coding as soon as possible.
My name is Vivof uh on the side. I work
on BAML. Um and today I have with me
special guest uh Dexter sadly can't make
it today. So, for all of you that are
hoping to see him, I'm really sorry
you're stuck with just myself, but
luckily we have Anders on um to make it
a lot more interesting and fun.
>> Yeah.
>> Anders, do you want to give a quick
intro about yourself? Uh I know you're a
YC founder. I have gotten to know you uh
for quite some time now. Um
>> Yeah.
>> And
>> uh first of all, is my mic working
properly?
>> Okay. All right. Uh yeah. So yeah, it's
been a it's been a while since we known
each other now. Um but yeah, so we did
the um YCS25 batch, but basically we're
building uh SageKit, which is like a
workflow automation platform. Uh it's
kind of like chat GPT meets Zapier. Like
you just sort of chat and it builds you
like workflow automations. So yeah,
very, you know, key thing to our product
experience is just having like a super
good like chat experience, right? So
there's a lot of things involved in sort
of making that kind of experience good,
right? And uh like making sure that
yeah, users always have sort of the
right thing happen at the right time
when they're on our platform. So
>> yeah, and I think the first time we met
is actually when you were working on a
thing called magnitude back at that
time. Um, and I and for everyone else
that we're going to talk about today is
we're going to talk about event- driven
actions. And why are we going to talk
about event- driven actions? Well,
because I think it's one of the most
interesting ways to go model how to go
build agents behind the scene. And we'll
get to the whiteboards really fast
before we get to coding in a second. But
the reason that we brought Anders on
today is because I think Anders built
their first thing called Magnitude as I
mentioned before, which was an open
source system. And I think you guys did
pretty well in Hacker News. They got a
bunch of GitHub stars around it. Um, and
I think the way I described it was kind
of like browser based but worked. Uh,
but worked.
>> Yeah, that's that's a good way to
describe it. Basically,
>> it's just like the I think you hit
number one on all the benchmarks for a
while.
>> Still are number one on the benchmarks.
Um, I know a bunch of the YC companies
that are in that space all use you guys.
I know a lot of startups down there used
you guys.
>> Um, and I happened to meet you because
uh I guess you were using BAML at the
time to go build it. But through that
interaction, I think eventually you
settled on this interesting really
interesting product idea which was along
the lines of I think we had a whiteboard
conversations once about it uh while we
were hanging out about how to build
event- driven actions and I remember we
were just like vibing and conver
conversing about it but it sounds like
you guys did it to like the nth degree.
>> Yeah. Before we get really into it, how
about we just show people what it feels
like and then we can talk about
technical architecture and everything
else once people get a sense of what's
like what does it mean to have an event
action because I think it can feel so
ambiguous along the way,
>> right? Yeah. Um should I go and share
here?
>> Yeah, go for it. Screen share.
Oh, shoot. I gota rejoin real quick.
>> Cool.
>> While everyone else is on here, uh, for
everyone else that's joining, um, how
many of you have actually built event-
driven actions by chance? Has anyone
built a kind of system that can be
really almost feel natural? I think the
closest that I have seen is probably
quad code to where you can interact with
it as it's going. And that was one of
the first innovations that they had. I
think that's what made quad code
personally so good. And then obviously
cursor copied it, everyone else copied
it. And everyone had the very simple
thing that you could do which is as you
typed code you actually could cancel the
previous message and make it go work.
But Claude did something very
interesting on launch which was it cued
a message. And that behavior pattern I
thought of queuing messages was
foundationally different than everything
else in a very subtle but massive way. I
think very similar to
a lot of the great UI innovations like
Amazon's oneclick buy. So subtle the
fact that you can just one click check
out without having to do anything else.
But it makes a huge difference. And I
think in AI stuff event driven and like
interruptions and queuing all these
other behaviors are really the
difference between like an okay app
versus an amazing app.
We've got someone working on it right
now. Um that's that's great. Um so
Andrew, let's show the demo and show how
it works and how it feels.
[clears throat]
>> Yeah. So
first of all,
generally speaking, right? So this is
like our our sort of chat experience,
right?
So let's say what I want to do is I want
to go scrape Reddit uh subreddit for
r/lang chain for everyone complaining
about structured outputs or complaining
about lang. Let's do that.
Uh and the categor and categorize the
types of complaints.
>> Okay,
we'll ask it a question after.
So, okay, let's let's make a
modification.
>> So, that's interesting. What you do is
you actually ban the inputs during
certain time periods when you don't
allow interruptions.
>> Yeah.
Okay. So, let me extend the plan there.
So, okay. So, just to be clear, yeah, we
don't um basically over the past couple
days, I was rethinking how sort of the
events should work in the chat and like
how we should best enable like stopping
and interruption and queuing messages
and stuff like that.
>> So, this is um not actually in our
production chat app yet, but I have like
another demo that's just like I
basically used when I was prototyping
the new
>> Yeah.
>> sort of architecture. Um, but this is
just sort of a general idea of like the
types of flows that you have in sort of
a very interactive chat app. So it's
like you have, you know, back and forth
messages, you have, you know, plan
approvals and stuff like that. You know,
a lot of the same stuff that you have in
like interfaces like cloud code and that
kind of thing.
And so if you weren't logged into like
some of these apps, sometimes you would
get like ooth flows happening in the
middle here. So there's a lot of like um
complex states that kind of come up
that'll just sort of like happen in the
chat. So it gets sort of like
interesting to basically manage all that
state and like figure out what should be
happening at a given time like at a
certain time like should the user be
able to send a message? Should they be
able to interrupt it? Should they be
able to authorize with a certain like a
connection?
Um and yeah, so there we go. So it's
it's basically just built a workflow for
us. And this is sort of like a summary
of what it's going to do. So it'll like
use Reddit. um review them for
complaints and it'll use like Gemini to
analyze them and then it will format
that. So yeah, we can just run that
basically. So it just builds it all
completely on its own
and then we run it and it's basically
like
using the Reddit
connector to
list the posts and then it's making a
bunch of AI calls to analyze them for
complaints. Makes sense.
>> Yeah.
>> So, how do we um how so talk to me about
how you what do where would you add
interruptions? Because we've talked
about this a bit and I think you have um
like interruptions and queuing. So, it
sounds like I can definitely send a
bunch of messages, but this looks very
linear,
>> right? Yeah. So, what you really want to
be able to do, right, and which we're
adding like tomorrow or something, um is
you want to be able to just queue up
messages however much you want. Like
right now if I like type another
message,
>> it should just do stuff.
>> It should it should just do stuff,
right?
>> Yeah.
>> And it's like I can send another
message, but I can't send another
message here. Right now it's just an
invalid state.
>> Yeah.
>> Um but ideally like Yeah. You know,
people want to be able to like send more
messages like maybe they have a thought
while it's building. So they want to
keep be able to like send things. So um
here's like right just a demo of sort of
what the new uh architecture vaguely
looks like that's sort of like very just
event to the max.
>> Yeah. Let me zoom in. This is a
>> and then we'll take a look at the code
pretty soon too. But I think this is
this I think it's
>> uh what one thing I find really
fascinating is always when we're able to
go look into this in a deep way and just
go check this out.
>> Yeah. So, if I, you know, I say hi, and
there's not a lot of scrolling here, but
you can see it stream back a response,
and these are all just sort of like
events like coming from, you know, the
LLM that are eventually streaming into
the chat. Um, but right, we might have
other types of events. So, it's like
tell me a long story. It's like another
type of event is like interruption,
right? So if we interrupt
that happens sort of concurrently during
this process of streaming and then the
question is like okay how do you deal
with that event in the context of like
okay we're also streaming from the LLM
um so like what's happening now based on
those events that occurred right those
like the sort of source of truth um in
terms of like we started the LLM
response it gave these chunks at this
point in time the user pressed the stop
button what should happen now right so
it's like basically react acts to that
it's like okay I need to stop you know
listening to the LLM I need to you know
present some sort of message that sort
of reflects what the user did um and
then you know put the user back in a
valid state where they can send more
messages. So yeah, the user can also
just, you know,
ceue up messages as well, right? And you
sort of have to think about like what
you want the behavior for queuing to be
like,
uh, we sort of followed like the cloud
code model here where it's like if you
send a message, it will start like
responding to it and then if you like
queue up more messages,
it's like tell me a long story.
uh if you like send a bunch of messages
during this point, it'll just sort of
like accumulate those and then once the
LM is done with its story, uh these will
basically all like resolve into the
context window. So it will like see all
of these at once and then respond again.
>> So I guess what I would say is like
let's talk about this a little bit more.
So what I'm going to do is I want to
maybe we should jump to whiteboards
because I think that often it might be
easier way to go describe this kind of
state because as we go see this
>> there's a lot of complicated things that
are happening. One is I I have this chat
thread this chat thread that's running
all the time. I'm guessing in some
backend API call because it can't run
directly from the front end.
>> Yep. And then some it sounds like the
most complicated thing here is what I'm
really doing is I'm sending a bunch of
commands from the front end and then I
have to update the world view and
somehow send a Wii view of the world
view back to the front end.
>> The analogy that I've always personally
found here is actually video games. If
you ever play like a multiplayer video
game of any kind,
>> that is, I think, the closest analogy to
building these kinds of agentic systems
because like for example, we might have
totally different lags in the world. And
what if I'm running and you like shoot
me
>> in your in your scope? It might actually
look like you actually landed the shot
and you killed me, but from my
perspective, I'm lagging in the world
view, it didn't actually hit me.
>> So,
>> right. Like what video games actually do
is they actually say we favor the person
that is like killing the person because
if it looks like they killed you,
>> it should actually kill you even if you
can't tell. And they actually correct in
that way because it feels really bad to
feel like you did the right thing and
then someone else uh because of their
internet lag didn't and world state kind
of lied based on what you thought.
>> Right.
>> Yeah. Yeah. It's basically like right
you have all these events happening,
right? And it's like what you show to
the user is always some variation of a
lie, right? It's like it's not the exact
you're not showing them literally every
single thing that happened, right? It's
like if you showed them like the exact
like function calling format that the
LLM used and the exact tool results that
the LM got back and all this kind of
stuff like basically what you want the
user to perceive is like different from
the truth and it's different from what
you want the LM to see also. So it's
like everyone see needs a different
version of the truth and so it's like
how do you manage that and then how do
you manage like the concurrency and
stuff?
>> Yeah. So what we should do is um we
should actually go ahead and um talk
through what's it called? Let me open
the whiteboard really fast so we can
actually draw this out because I think
it's going to be a lot better.
>> Um and I'll send you the link as well.
Give me one second.
>> Share screen.
Skelelet draw
take over skele
um invite. Sorry, I should invite you.
Uh sorry about this. Dexter usually does
this stuff [laughter]
live collaboration
and then I'll send this to you uh only.
So while we're actually going to go talk
about this
what we really want to do is we want to
figure out a way to go draw this out
from a system architecture. So what we
have is we have a front end. And in our
front end, what we're going to want to
do is we're going to want to send a
regular system of events to our back
end. And once we send system of data to
our back end, what we want to make sure
is whatever this is triggering should
not directly trigger the actual um
it should not trigger the direct uh
what's it called? The direct agent loop.
because if it triggers a direct agent
loop and it responds directly to to the
user in a very linear way, we can no
longer interrupt the system. So what we
need to make sure that we do is we need
to go ahead and somehow send data from
the front end to the back end.
And once the back end is gone, this
needs to kick off some task in some form
factor where this will go write
information
to some central database.
get task and then somehow this database
is or database like thing and somehow
this front end will listen to state
actions coming from the uh database and
now what you can do at least and correct
me if you're if I'm wrong on this Anders
and you guys do something different
because I think it'd be a very
interesting conversation to have is as
events come in as new events come in you
can basically have your agent task
somehow be loading these events from uh
new events Oh, sorry. New can also be
written to the database and then your
agent task can also have a readwrite
system from here somehow.
>> Great. Yeah.
>> Go ahead.
>> Yeah. So, yeah, the way I think about
this, right, is that right, the event
the event stream and the events
produced, they're coming from a lot of
different places actually, right? And
it's like,
>> okay,
>> um, so it's like you have different sort
of types of events that I that I think
about, right? So this is like um Right.
So this is what like the user over here.
This is uh
right. So I mean obviously we have you
know an LLM in here.
>> This is a very different style. It's
going to be an interesting graph. Uh
[laughter]
>> I can fix that. You can just keep
drawing. I'll fix.
>> Okay.
Right. But we have a lot of different
things like contributing to the event
stream. Right. So it's like we obviously
have an LLM in here. Um we have you know
we have some kind of strategy for
especially with streaming like we
usually have some sort of way of like
interpreting or like parsing um what the
LM is doing. So usually it's actually
like this. It's like we're doing that
and then that's going into the event
stream. Um
and then we sometimes have you know like
handling for like doing different like
tool calls or other things. So it's like
we have some like
tool calls and maybe sometimes the
parser goes and does a tool call first
and then that becomes sort of like an
event, right? So it's like there's a lot
of different things that can sort of
contribute to that, right? And so sort
of think what the the confusing part
becomes is like okay, how do you
um who's sort of in control? Like what's
like what's in control of this whole
like loop? Uh how do things like feed
events into each other?
um and and sort of what happens there.
So
yeah, the the way like there's a lot of
different ways that you can structure
that, right? So it's like we have sort
of
in this, you know, little diagram, we
just have this event stream thing here,
but it's like
um there's different ways that you could
do that, right? could be like
one sort of continuous sort of event
stream from like LLM to like parser to
like um some sort of representation for
both the user and for the
LLM, right? So it's like you have
different ways that you need to display
the event stream.
Um,
and
yeah, so I'd say like you basically
yeah, you basically have things that add
to the event stream in different ways
and you have things that need to like
perceive that event stream is like the
main idea I would say.
>> So is is the right way to think about
this? You basically have a function in
your code somewhere else. So an event
handler that takes in some event kind of
some any of the many events that you
have and then based on the event kind.
Oh, this is center text. We did not want
that. What you end up doing is you end
up basically saying, hey, if it's an LLM
stream, if it's an LLM event,
[clears throat] I should say like a
parsed event, then you do something else
where like maybe it's like write send to
UI
of some kind. Otherwise, like if it's
like a if it's a tool tool response of
some kind, you say like do action where
you do the next action over here,
>> right?
>> And you go fill this out. And then if
it's like if user request,
>> you end up saying something like Q uh
action of some kind where you like cue
an action. And this is basically it's
triggering a almost like a cron job
that's running all the time where like
[snorts] every single system that you
have like every agent task isn't
actually a whole loop. It's actually a
system that's just adding a new event
through a massive like event log of
what's happening.
>> Exactly. Yeah. I think basically the way
I think about it is like Yeah. It's like
a reactive system. So it's like it's not
instead of like thinking about it as
like a while loop um it's more like cues
of events.
>> Yeah. So your worldview model so that's
interesting. It's a it's actually a
different worldview model than what I've
used in the in the past where like my
way of representing the worldview has
actually been like I have a giant state
object that represents the state of the
world of some kind. It sounds like your
world view is actually you have like an
a ve or an array.
>> Yep. of actions that have happened in
the past and this is what represents
your state. It's not to say either one
is good or bad but this is what you
found is really easy because then what
you say is for example the way that you
pro tell me if this is wrong or not. The
way that you implement queuing is that
you say like a Q event
is a thing that gets pushed into your
array and once the next action finishes
you go back and you see if there's any
cute events that are not
>> done yet. Right. Yeah. It's it's very
sort of native to that system, right? So
yeah, so what we had sort of in the past
was sort of more like a state based
model where we just have a state and we
mutate it and it's you know it's you
know very reasonable kind of makes sense
like you can just sort of change the
state as needed react to that you know
do think different things depending on
what that state is at the current time
uh and that kind of thing. But the
problem is like what we did more and
more over time is like we started uh
sort of mixing these paradigms because
it's like oh well we need like a whole
like log of everything that happened in
the chat so that we can like view it
right in the chat and also the LLM needs
to be able to perceive it in a certain
way in terms of like converting that to
something that goes in the context
window. Um
and then it became very unwieldy to like
maintain both like these events that are
like the source of truth for like what
happened and then also like a separate
state which is like we have to keep it
synchronized with like what happened and
then so basically
um what I wanted to do instead was just
like okay what if everything is just
basically a pure function of the events
that actually occurred. Um, and so like
you can have like representations of
state in this model where you sort of
centralize around events still, but
they're just like
functions of that event.
>> Describe I'm going to try and describe
what a user might do and how someone
else can view the code and then we'll
take a look at the code really fast. So
in this case, what I have is a user
started off with some user event with
some request. Maybe it's as simple as
just like hello and your agent started
responding with like hello how really
fast and then right at that point the
user said wait. So there and if they
cued the event, the behavior ends up I'm
guessing something like this where you
get a bunch more stream text of some
other text
>> and at some point your state engine
recognizes that like obviously when
you're streaming you can also say like
done streaming
and now your user invent uh uh your
agent system can say as soon as it the
event handler for the done event goes
and checks the queue for this specific
user ID or this specific conversation ID
and says
Q event. Well, let's give this event an
ID of like ID of some kind. Sorry, let
me make bigger and too small. ID equals
1. And then what I can do is I can say
like handle uh handled event and now I
can handle event id equals 1 where it'll
actually treat this and transform this
into another user event of like wait
at this point. And now
this has basically been handled. So now
the system will start streaming and send
the response into the user.
>> Right. One way to handle a queueing.
>> Yeah. But yeah, the main the main thing
here is that um when this queue event
happens, right, we have to immediately
right interrupt whatever thread or is
going on that's handling the streaming
part, right? And ignore the rest of it
right away. Well, no, not the interrupt.
The queue event.
>> Oh,
>> yeah. Sorry.
>> You mean just literally?
>> Oh, yeah.
>> Oh, oh yeah. Oh, yeah. Yeah. My bad.
Yeah. For queuing events. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. So, yeah, we let it keep going.
Um,
>> on the other hand, let's talk about the
second part, which is interrupt event.
Let's say the user sent this as an
interrupt instead
of Q. Oops.
Interrupt.
Well, interrupts are I think very very
similar to queuing in that same in that
same form factor where oh sorry one
second. Um
I have to reload the page so my view
length is better
go back to the right area. Click on new.
So interrupt is very very similar to
queuing where instead of queuing the
event though all these systems that come
in what you can tell your back end is
hey don't add these events to my I mean
you can cancel it as well but you can
also just say like just don't add these
to the queue like basically don't add
them into the queue and spin up a new
event as if this happened. And you can
do what's interesting here is you can
choose how you handle these previous
events. You can choose to maintain them
in the record or you can actually say
that actually you know what I am these
are bad so I will just like delete them
after the fact even though they
technically exist in the record and my
the my world view when I query and when
I show in the UI how to represent this
this exists but I don't render it or I
can delete it and purge it from the
event record in any way myself.
>> Yeah. Exactly. And I think that's the
nice thing about this type of system,
right, is that you can basically just
look at what happens and sort of have
however you handle events decide like
what what is supposed to be viewed or
perceived when like you know this type
of situation happens where you have like
okay these events were streamed but then
the interrupt happened. It's like okay
do I just ignore the ones that happened
after that? Do I ignore all of them? And
you can sort of you know implement that
however you want.
>> Yeah. And like once you model the world
in this way where it's just like a
sequence of elements that are being
collected and like drawn upon like
writing code for this is actually very
simple. I'm guessing like this code
system is not that hard. And in terms of
actually you like rendering in the UI
well that's also very easy because you
just say how do I render the sequence of
events? And
>> you can do that in any which way that
you want as a developer. You can render
like and show the stream text. We know
how to do that. You can render and show
um show cute events. You can not show
cute events. You can show interruptions.
You can show middle states. You can show
like the entire conversation history.
You can go back and fork at any point
because it's just copy this screenshot,
copy this action array of everything up
before this event and start copying from
here.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I'd say there's like a
little bit of like
just like
setup in terms of thinking about your
agent as a sequence of events and not as
like just oh I have state and I mutate
it but like once you start thinking
about it that way yeah you get a lot of
>> benefits from that like you know some of
the things you mentioned
>> you know what this really reminds me of
this really reminds me of how like
database transactions are made.
>> Yeah. um in some ways where like you
basically have in a lot of ways you just
write a bunch of logs to some event file
and eventually the database becomes like
consistent on its own by saying like
these event files eventually have to be
recorded in the database
>> with some yeah it's kind of like that in
a way yeah um right yeah so you can yeah
like yeah the key things that you can
really get out of this are you have sort
of right you have the one source of
events instead of like state that you're
mutating on the back end state that
you're mutating on the front end those
might get out of sync, right? You have
all sorts of like weird things. It's
like everything just driven by sort of
this one engine that's handling the
events and that kind of thing and it can
just send like okay front end like you
should look like this at this point in
time based on the events.
>> I'm actually really curious to see what
this code ends up looking like in
practice. Someone asked a really
important question before we go into
that
>> um which is do you store the same events
in the same table in a database? I my
hunch says probably yes. I suspect your
database is basically a union of events.
>> Yeah, it's literally just the way the
way I've done this is it just it's just
one array of events just in a you know
database column. It's just um
>> I'm guessing you're you're
>> just like a discriminated union of
different like event types. Um, that's
it.
>> And I'm guessing it it's just basically
like event and then you do a group by
user ID and convo ID and now you have
your entire event history for every
single and like time stamp and obviously
all the metadata.
>> Yep. Yeah. So that's basically what it
is. Yeah. So you just an array of events
and so the representation is like
extremely simple, right? You can just
load those events and do whatever you
want with them.
>> Yeah. And you can load as many of the
events you want. You can get the most
recent 50. You can get the most, you can
get all of them forever. You the first
10, the last 10. It's all up to you.
>> Yeah. And it's extremely like uh
debugable and testable as well. Um, like
when you think about like one one thing
that was hard when we were sort of
>> building our our chat is just like it's
hard to test it without like running the
the back end and the front end and and
like testing different scenarios like
manually and that kind of thing like
with sort of a traditional system where
you have some sort of state that you're
managing on the back end and on the
front end that's trying to synchronize
because you don't really know from the
backend code alone what the front end is
going to look like at any point in time.
But if you have sort of everything
driven by the events and like your back
end is basically just telling what your
front end and what it should look like
exactly at any point in time based on
those then it becomes very testable
because you can just write tests that
are like okay at this point in time I
expect the interrupt button to be
available or not based on these events
that occurred.
>> It's it's another analogy for this for
me is like very similar to like use
state and react. When I write use state
and react I can like how do I debug
state that is bad? Well, I usually just
hardcode the initial condition of the
state. I say change the state to this
like just show me what the rendering
looks like and then I debug it really
easily.
>> Um because like React just says assume I
have state of this shape and now render
it however I want and it's a really easy
transaction for me to go make as a
developer.
Um we should uh we should get the code.
Uh we got like two interesting questions
while you set up the code and you go
screen share for that. Take over my
screen share while you go do that. Yeah,
>> which is um where do we persist the
context for LLMs in this case? And I
think this is a really interesting
question that all people ask, but this
goes back to how we we've talked about
this in the episode quite a few times,
which is what the heck is an agent?
Well, let me see if I can pull that up.
We talked about this in the 12 uh
factors um selecting thousand tools from
MCP
uh tool. Let me pull this up really
fast. I'm gonna take I'm gonna take over
the screen share for one more second.
>> Okay, my bad.
>> It's okay. Um screen
we talked about in this episode
actually. And when you go think about an
agent loop really fast, what I have
personally found is u take it here
really fast. Sorry.
You can view every single agent as
basically a thing a model as just a
thing whose only job it is to do which
is
close up. You take some context window
that you're building up over time and
you ask the model to do something that
is very stateless which is determine the
next step. See the question that you're
asking is how do you build your context
window? Well, your context window is
also really just a projection of this
state. You take this state and you turn
it into a chat prompt of some kind. And
that's just a function that you can
write which says or turn your action
array or event array into a chat prompt.
Now, I suspect Andrews will be showing
this code when he talks through this.
But let's get into it. All yours,
Anders.
>> All righty.
>> And as people have questions, keep
sending them. We'll try and uh answer
them as fast as we can.
Okay.
>> Yeah. All right. So, here's the code for
um sort of that demo that I was showing
that
>> bun. I love it.
>> Where do you see the bun at?
>> I thought bun.serve.
>> Oh, [laughter]
yeah. Bun. Um, so
yeah, when I was playing around with
sort of the ideas for doing this very,
you know, event driven thing, um, one
thing that I, you know, had, uh, heard
about but not experimented enough with
was effect TS. Um, and so I'm I'm an
effect TS newbie. Um but for people who
don't know it's like you know a library
that makes it
>> hard
>> gives gives gives a lot of tools um for
for TypeScript in terms of doing a lot
of different stuff like error handling
but also like streams and just like
piping things between other things and
just like all sorts of different like
transformations.
And so
um
yeah, basically it became like obvious
that like it was like a pretty good way
to structured this type of system where
you have sort of inherently like a lot
of streams of events like feeding into
each other uh and different stuff like
that. So yeah, this is a very like this
demo is like very eventt. So um yeah,
basically like how this has been like
structured here is just like effectively
like the the the the back end here
that's actually receiving the websocket
connections from the front end and it's
running the whole chat has basically
these different like services that are
at any time going to basically observe
events and like maybe produce events
also. Um, and so
these are all sort of controlled by like
an event bus which is like going to be
getting different events from like the
front end. Say a user sends a chat
message that will go in here, right? So
it's like let's take a look at a
specific example. Um,
yeah. So it's like basically when
something wants to send an event back
into sort of the engine that's has these
different things perceiving the events
uh it can use this event bus it can like
publish the event and it will basically
be subscribed to by the other things. Um
so
>> so let's take a look at some of the
events if you're down. Why don't we look
at
>> Yeah. Yeah. Let's start with um the
events right. So yeah. So here's what
some of the events looks like for
example. Um
so basically these are all the types of
events that can live in this event bus
and can be like sent to it as sort of
like from external source or like
um sent from one of these event handlers
back into the system to be you know
transformed or something. Um, so like
user message, you know, obviously that's
like going to come from the front end.
Um, and it's going to sort of go into
the system and it'll be reacted to in
some way or another depending on like
what's currently going on. So like if we
look at
like what's Oh man, I've got like Hold
on. Just delete this.
>> You can just filter forts files. Just
hit the down arrow on the left or the
dot dot dots.
if you need
>> it or might be TSX if you're looking for
your front end.
>> Uh
>> no, but it's like um yeah, so it's like
this is like the message function that's
just like on the server itself. So like
when it gets a websocket message from
the front end that's like I want to send
a user message then it will basically
like publish that to the event bus right
and so we can see like what uses that
right so we have basically
a subscriber to that event bus right
which is like this messages state
service right and basically what this is
just trying to do at any time is
actually basically trying to like
perceive like a current state out of
what events are being streamed that have
to do with that are like message related
right so it's like user message or like
different like LLM chunks or other
things
>> so basically right
>> and this is interesting so it's not that
you don't have a state object it's that
you don't keep the state object as your
representation of truth
>> you have an you have an event history
>> and you turn the event history into a
state object in every single every
single time you do something with it.
>> Exactly.
>> So then you're now you say now given the
state object now what's the next action?
>> Right. Yeah. You could right. So you
could imagine like in a sort of normal
like um state based system where you
just sort of like mutating state you
would like you would just have an object
like this and you would just initialize
it to this and then like you would be
like whenever you finish streaming a
message you'd like append it to this
list or something. Um, and like whenever
you get a message and you look at
everything and you're like, "Oh, I think
this should be cued." You would add it
to here instead. And then you'd like
move it between these or something. So
all we're really doing here is like
we're saying, "Okay, we're still going
to like this is still helpful to like
perceive something as like a state of
like
>> yeah,
>> different things in a certain context,
but we can construct that purely from
the events that are actually happening
in a specific way. So that's what this
is really doing here, right? this
message state thing is it's just
perceiving the event stream as like
what's currently going on with the
messages. Um so like are we streaming
are any of them cued? Um like how many
tokens are we using? Like all that kind
of stuff
>> and this can change at any time because
you're just it's just a simplified view
of the event history because you're like
I don't want to look at the act the time
at which cute events happen. I just want
to like pull out all the cute events and
just have them available really fast.
>> Exactly. Yeah. you can just decide
exactly what this needs to be like what
what information is important to hold on
to and that kind of stuff right so yeah
and then so like an example of like
something you'd actually do right I is
like if we look at
what's actually happening here right so
it's like processing
user messages so this is a specific
stream for just the events that have
that type user message these are
basically
coming from the front end through the
websocket. Um, and basically we have the
stream to handle those specifically. Um,
and basically based on our current
state, right? So we're looking at our
current state like if we're streaming
and that kind of stuff. So if we're
currently streaming, we aren't going to
send it right away. We're not aren't
going to trigger the LM to start
streaming again. We're just going to
update it and we're going to put that in
the ceued user messages, right? instead
of the the normal messages and otherwise
right we just add it to sort of the
normal message array sort of the history
here and in addition right we also have
sort of an effect right so we also
trigger the LLM right to respond right
which is the sort of this utility here
which again is checking some things and
then it's producing another event right
so
it's like if we get a message and
um you know it's not currently streaming
then we're going to
cue
this event right lm response started and
that's going to basically trigger an LM
[clears throat] response. So we could we
could trace that further here if we
wanted.
>> And the reason and just to be very clear
like the reason we add that LM response
started is because we want to somehow
show in our UI that we've we've handled
the message in some way or the message
is like addressed and we should show
some UI indicator to the user or like we
shouldn't cue we shouldn't just run
another message right now because
there's something else in progress at
this moment.
>> Right? So it serves a dual purpose,
right? So first of all, yeah, it could
be represented in the UI if we wanted,
but also it means that we can delegate
sort of what it means to start an LLM
response to like another part of the
codebase, right? Which is like more
dedicated for that purpose, right? So
that's what like this is here, right? So
it's like um that goes back into the
event bus and now the LLM service picks
it up, right? So this is not a thing
responsible for maintaining chat state
anymore, but this is um a thing
responsible for basically managing a
stream of chunks that come back from an
LLM and deciding what to do with them.
Right? So again, we're subscribing to
the LLM response started event and then
basically we're going to listen to that
and then when we get one of those types
of events
we're going to do a few different
things, right? So first of all, we
reference actually a different state,
right? And this is sort of a a state
managed by another service, right? LM
memory state which is sort of the
perception of the messages as context
which we can look at in a second but
basically that gets like messages that
are nice for the LLM um and they're sort
of like in a a format that's ready to go
for that um
>> and and the idea is that you can remove
all the croft and state signal like you
don't for getting messages in the
current state you really only want the
final LM response from every LM past LM
interaction you want the chat thread
with the most recent views. So
interruptions and stream text and
everything else is removed and you
really want to simplify this.
>> You can decide like exactly what you
want to go into the context window,
right? It's like very explicit. Like
it's not like a lot of the times like I
feel like when you're building an agent
loop, the easiest thing to do is just
like you're just appending messages to
like a list when it's like you know use
like ro user this content, ro assistant
this content and then everything is
coupled together. like your control loop
is like looking at those messages and
like deciding what to do based on what
those look like. You're feeding them to
your LLM. You're trying to display them
on the UI, but like when your agent gets
more complex, these sort of states
diverge. Like what you want to show on
your UI is no longer the same as what
you want to show to the LLM. Um, and so
it makes more sense to produce those
states instead.
>> Projections.
>> Yeah. Different.
>> I think there's a really question that's
happening here because I think
>> I I think I see what you're doing. You
basically have this giant event catalog
and based on different use cases, you're
turning it into different subsets of
that catalog based on how you want to go
use it.
>> So case of a new user event comes in,
what you want to ask yourself is the
only thing you really care about is, is
anything active happening right now? If
something active is happening right now,
the new user message is a cued message.
>> If nothing active is happening right
now, the new user message is the next
action that should happen next. And I
think while and right over here, you did
another projection where you said the LM
is going to interact. So I want a subset
of the messages that I want to send to
the LM. But I think there's something
that might be confusing a few folks
really fast, which is a really important
question.
>> When do they get persisted? Like I get
that I could keep this thing in memory,
but like do you save this into a
database anywhere right now? And if you
don't, where would you because how does
that work?
>> Right? So in this like demo code,
there's it's just all in memory, right?
But it's it's very easy to
>> can you show the data structure that
keeps everything in memory because I
think that would also make it a lot more
clear.
>> Yeah. I mean effect doing some magic.
>> So it's it's effect doing some magic.
Okay.
>> So, it's it's all being basically it's
all persisted in memory basically in the
like the stream buffers and that kind of
thing. Um, from my limited understanding
of effect at least I think that I think
that's where it lives.
>> Right. But
>> but if you were to save in a database,
can you show the pointing code when you
would do this? I suspect it's an event
bus,
>> right? Yeah. So, you could do this. Um,
>> I suspect if someone publishes a new
event, I suspect you do it on publish.
>> So, you could do it on publish, right?
But it's like it depends on the
frequency of persistence that you want
and and sometimes, right, you don't want
to persist everything right away because
it's like you could have sort of invalid
states like you imagine like
>> um if someone's just interrupted an LM
in the middle of a bunch of stuff, like
it's like, oh, do you want to persist it
there or do you want to wait for like
the LM to finish its turn? or like if an
LM is like in the middle of streaming
like it doesn't really make sense to
persist it on every chunk right so it's
like you have to decide like when does
it make sense to persist it um but
basically yeah you could have
um one way to do it was just like you
just have a subscriber to um all the
events right and you just have like
basically
>> and can you show let me just write some
pseudo code really fast or maybe let's
write let's write the code really fast I
would show how it get persistent in
effect. I think also for those of you
that don't know, effect is actually a
pretty good library. Um, if you're
trying to build extremely resilient
system, uh, effect will make it easier
to go do that kind of thing. And in the
world of LMS where you have a lot of
error handling, it is easier. But that
said, it is a long to learn. Uh, so
>> let's ask let's ask Claude code because
I I'm not very good at writing effect,
but Claude is pretty good at it.
>> I I [laughter]
love it. How would we persist uh all
events in the event bus so we can
reload the chat later?
>> Yeah, there you go. Um it'll figure it
out. Um and it will go write the code
and I think can you and we'll be able to
see a git diff really fast as well. So
that'll be able to just look at the
diff. So that will give a little
>> while that's running. Thank you for
queuing that up. Let's go continue
reading the code.
>> Yep. Um, so yeah, maybe we could look at
another example of sort of one of those
projections.
>> Let's look at I think there I think the
question there was actually really good,
which was how does this actually go into
an LM? I I think we should go look I
want to see your projection of what
events are you discarding when you
create this giant event array from all
the possible events to the LM memory
state. And you can if you could put side
by side the LM memory state that you're
building and on the other side if you
can put the
um and on the other side you can put all
the events. So we can actually just like
see it side by side. I think it' be
really cool.
>> And could you hit command? Yes, exactly.
Thank you.
>> Oops.
There we go. Um, right. So I mean in
this example, right, the the
events for the LM are we're just sort of
rendering it out to just a simple
message with,
>> you know, user assistant role and just
string content, right? And then we have
all these types of events that could be
encountered sort of over the over the
time where it processes events. Um
and yeah, [snorts] so what we do is we
basically just
we can listen to the specific events
that we care about or not. But in this
case, we're actually looking at the
message state. So we're actually looking
at another state in this state, right?
So we're looking at the messages state,
which we looked at earlier. um which
again is basically just keeping track of
a list of messages and some other
information.
And because that's really the only thing
that we care about for showing the LLM
in this case as well, it makes more
sense to just
um look at that than like redo all that
logic of like trying to figure out when
a chunk should be appended to the last
message and like all this different
stuff. So the LLM memory state here
which is constructing the specific
messages for the LLM is just going to
tap into that state that we've already
constructed. So it's just mapping those
messages that are in that state
to right these simple versions that can
be passed to an LM. So uh in this demo
right we have sort of text events which
are just like you know from the user to
the LM or the LM to the user right just
sort of standard messages
>> or we have like function calls right so
it's like basically we parsed the LLM
response and we decided okay this is a
function call
>> on that format function call so people
can go see this I think it's going to
help make it a lot more tangible
>> yeah so this is like basically the the
function syntax that we told the len to
use for context text here, right? So we
we told it to use this sort of XML
format,
right? So when the LM responds and wants
to call a function, it does something
like this. And so when we and so we
parse that out, right? And we can
validate the parameters and that kind of
stuff. But then we instead of storing it
directly and sort of feeding it back
since we want it to be sort of this
clean um format as an event we have to
just reconstruct what we want the LM to
see that it's set right so basically
we're we're reconstructing that format
for the function call here. So that's
just so you can keep everything be
really in sync with what you're with
what you wanted to do. And you could
have done this and you could have done
this in many which ways, but you're I'm
guessing you just found that since
you're doing codegen, I'm guessing XML
works pretty well.
>> Yeah. So this is this is um the same
uh XML format that like anthropic models
use internally. So we just imitate that.
>> Good to mimic it. Exactly. Yes.
Especially if you're using anthropic
models, you should just mimic whatever
they're doing.
>> Yep. So that's why we have that specific
format there.
>> So it sounds like really I think the big
takeaway for almost everyone that's on
this and like what if you're down to you
should commit this code to the AI that
works repo in the folder for today's
event. I think people might have fun
running this code and playing out with
them for themselves and just like
understanding what's happening.
>> Yeah, sure.
>> Um but just things like some final
closing thoughts as we're out here. And
also if people have questions, feel free
to chime in. Uh we've got a pretty hard
stop today, so we'll be stopping right
on time. Um,
so what's the big takeaway here? How
hard in your mind? How hard is this to
build? Like on a scale of 1 to 10, 10
being like Linux.
>> So I think I think the the real question
here is like how complicated is your
agent? Like how many interactions and
like possible states are there at any
point in time, right? And like like if
you're building a simple, you know, back
and forth chat agent, like this is like
completely overkill, you know? It's like
you can just you can just store the
messages and and and just show that and
to the user, show that to the LM, like
whatever.
>> Um
but yeah, we're I mean, the reason that
I I started thinking about this in the
first place is that um we were just sort
of, you know, we have so many different
things going on in our chat UI and our
product because like you know, we have
like um You can screen share again and
show show what you mean.
>> Right. So
>> we have a lot of different things. You
can build you can build a full plan. You
can run it could be running code and
maybe you want to change the code. Maybe
you want to change the pipeline while
it's running the pipeline.
>> Like that's very complicated interaction
to model.
>> Yeah. It's like I could be like um also
email this to myself.
>> Yeah.
>> And it's like okay now it has to think
about like
>> it has to think about like okay what's
what's in the current workflow like how
do I
>> oh yeah it's also seeing like errors.
It's also perceiving errors like from
the workflow runs like when we run it it
will also like know about what happened
during the run. So it's like making a
fix based on that.
the the thing I think that would really
suck about that which is you said also
emailed to myself maybe you've been
running the pipeline for like 15 minutes
already and it's been running and
collecting a bunch of data and now it's
basically just going to throw all that
away and make a whole new pipeline and
then say now let's run it again
>> and whereas if you did it with your
event driven system you could say this
is this is how I want to modify the
pipeline you could run another event
that says what's a diff of this new
pipeline versus the old pipeline the
diff is very small and now you and now
it's basically just kind of working
along the way.
>> Yeah. Yeah. But basically, right? Yeah.
We we have like a lot of different types
of interactions happening, right? It's
like it's editing. So, under the under
the hood, this is basically like a
coding agent. Like the workflow is code
and it's editing it.
>> Yeah.
>> Um, so it's it's like a coding agent,
but then it's also like adding these
connectors which require like a specific
OOTH flow, which requires like human
approval, and then it's also like
proposing these plans and it's like,
okay, the user has to approve or reject
those. And it's like okay if they
approve them it has to also ask for the
ooth and then what happens if they
reject one of those. It's like all these
like different variations of state and
it it gets like really unwieldy if you
don't have sort of a system for like
understanding it right and I think
having sort of everything be a
projection of the events allows you to
like have very clear views of those
events in the exact ways that you need
to actually understand what's going on.
I think it's kind of like React, right?
Technically, use state is really really
overkill. All you want to do is build a
website,
>> but it turns out the minute you add
interactivity, it's there's no simpler
way. And that little bit of complexity
just makes it a lot easier to build that
website in the way that we want to.
>> But over here, you really, it's the same
thing. Like yes, it's a little complex
to think about everything as a
projection from like your event history
and your event array, but once you've
done that, you really have a beautifully
simple system where everything is really
just a readonly interaction on the
current view of the world.
>> Here's my current worldview. Go do
something with it. Here's my current
worldview and it keeps changing. And
someone asked a really good question.
It's like, could tools also write events
to the stream? The answer is yes. They
definitely could because there's just
they're just adding events to this
database that we have. Uh if I were to
share screen again, one second.
Yep.
>> If we go back to what we were sharing
over here, what everything is doing is
fundamentally we're just adding data to
this database which is user ID, convoy
ID, and event. And you just keep pushing
more and more data into that. And that
is your current worldview. And the next
time your system runs or handles on
events, you just go do that. If any of
you have ever built like an event
handler or web hook service, that's
basically what you're doing. An event
comes in, handle the event, you get the
world view, and you go do stuff with it.
>> It's funnily enough, this paradigm
exists in so many elements software. The
more and more I think about it,
>> yeah.
>> Um like the more I'm thinking like this
is just everywhere.
>> It's just that most of us haven't had to
write code that has dealt with this, so
it feels really foreign. But all of us
have used code that has done this in
some form factor or another.
[clears throat]
>> Yeah.
Yeah, it's just sort of like it's a
product of right the the chat loop gets
really complex and ugly.
>> The chat loop is so disgusting to
maintain forever
>> and it's just like ew like what I'm I'm
like holding these events like I have
this chat history. So basically before I
was like had this like you know history
of events for the UI I had like event
like or like messages for the UI
messages for the LM some sort of like
mutated you know mutated state that's
like tracking other things and it's just
like gez like I can't even think about
like what's happening at any point in
time. So it's just like very very
non-productive at some point when the
when the chat agent gets complex enough.
So yeah.
>> Um so I think we're gonna have to close
it off here. I've got a sadly a hard
stop today. Uh normally we will stay on
for questions and answers. Now if any of
you um do have more questions about this
definitely definitely uh we'll send out
an email update with this and send your
questions there. You can definitely ask
questions on the BAML Discord as well.
We'll post a link on there in a second
as well. Um and you can find the link on
there if you want to sign up for next
week's episode. We're going to have
another really fun episode. Uh sign up
on our link over here. This has been AI
Networks. We've got Anders over here
helping us go. actually wrote a whole
demo, made it work, showed a ventor in
action a really cool way. So, uh, thank
you for making time for that. Follow
them on Twitter, check out their demo,
check out their product. It's really
freaking cool. It gets really deep. And
I'm super excited once you have it the
event driven loop you show in the demo
of live in the code. It's going to make
it even more fun to play around with.
Uh, but for everyone else, thank you for
making time out of your day to come
listen to us. Um, this has been fun.
>> Yeah,
>> another episode out the out the window.
All right, we'll send an email update to
everyone that's watching. Uh, thank you
everyone.